hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome
anyway nice tootsies
um were your toes always turquoise
because that's awesome
proud of you
um anyway I'm gonna go in another vent
because never mind I'm screwed I forgot
about this oh oh you go faster crawl
faster oh
oh well I can't run out of Sprint I did
anyway
I just said don't do that and I did it
all right here we go
great thanks thank you thank you for
that
and there you go all right well that was
something I didn't ever need to remember
oh more that's great good
you gotta do it again
[Music]
you you are
oh you're not
oh where am I
whoa Pizza uh
uh
uh uh uh uh
ah oh
oh
ah okay
all right thank you for that
pretty lunchbox oh boy there really
aren't that many Real Collectibles
there's none actually if you think about
it okay good kids used to put their
lunches in these
not anymore
okay good anyway
but
what do I do oh the door it just opens
right of course that would be a thing
I thought the end goal is being in the
fazer blast place
I thought that was the whole point
wasn't wasn't that what Gregory said go
to fat
oh I finally have a clear signal Gregory
I shut down all the security nodes I'm
in the Roxy party garage am I close
almost there's still one note left
that's keeping the underground field
where Brooks is the final note you need
to deactivate her
it's so dark down here
you know it was already obvious
it was already obvious
it was already really really obvious but
also happy
happy birthday
also where was that door
where's the damn security door that I
saw before
my saw door and it opened when I looked
at it and you couldn't always look at it
you had to manually zoom out
I never found what that was I don't
think I ever will
fine
oh yeah okay
then good
anything over there
and also why is Roxy a node
it doesn't make any sense look I don't
know what I've been deactivating besides
the children that's been obvious
but it's not good whatever it is it's
not good
what am I hearing
what am I hearing what am I hearing what
am I hearing
what am I hearing how did that happen
how did that happen Roxy Roxy no proxy
Cassie
welcome back Cassie you remember me
is this a choice or is this not a choice
is this a non-choice
is this one of those no choice things
or do I have a choice
hello
welcome back Cassie hi
your special day
I remember
do you still like carrot cake
it has been some time since I saw you
last if I remember correctly it is on
the 11th
I remember because you are number one
twice
have you booked your party
I'm sure your friends will show up this
time
what
what the frick
it's a no choice thing but good God all
right
you know
what what do you want me to do just what
I'm here for
that was my mission from the beginning
deactivate
for children that was the goal all right
whatever
if any loss children's souls are in you
oh man I don't know why it's necessary
don't think just do it well this is not
giving me a choice here so I'm not gonna
think
here we go I guess because I got no
choice can't toggle The Mask or anything
so
whatever thanks Roxy I mean I guess they
tried to make it easier by
what are you doing uh
oh
well I can't
[Applause]
Rock
oh I can't
uh
wait no how do I fill up every Square
here we go no that won't do it
oh God
I can't all right I'll just
I'll leave this one open
[Music]
Cassie
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry
well as a robot she could just turn back
on so it's really not that sad right
thank you
why do I feel like I admit
stop floating I don't feel like I missed
something
you ever feel like you missed something
you ever feel like there's something
right
oh definitely that's not right
hello
well done that was the last security
note I have located the source of your
friends radio signal it is coming from
under the Raceway you are now leaving
the vanic network coverage zone of
course I am
oh that's blood good
I bet I bet it's because I missed that
one
floor mop I bet it's from the very and
the ver I knew that I did I knew that I
did and I knew it and it's ah
I'm telling you if that's what it is I'm
gonna oh you don't understand the Rage
that's gonna be inside my soul you don't
even know the Rage that's gonna be in my
soul if it's discovered
ready for the rage because that's coming
after the sad
I'm gonna go cry a lot
then I'm gonna kick some ass
that's what I'm gonna do
open
yeah that's what you should be doing
when I'm done with you what am I doing
oh right of course
laughs
it's all right okay Cassie
well back to the old familiar places
Gregory when I find you
I'm gonna ring your neck
okay all right what oh oh none of that
that is a big Freddy head
uh-huh
I'm glad I came to this place
this has been such a fun time
I killed my favorite animatronic
oh I am such a good person
I haven't seen another one of those
floor mops I'm almost positive I'm
almost 100 positive that I missed one
and I know it woo
cool no
oh you should have picked up the spare
stupid flashlight ah it's okay uh
thankfully I'm in the glowy caves
definitely not radiation
anything that glows is probably good for
me
what
oh what the frick
warmer what is that
how long has happened have those been
around
are those things that I could have had
what is that
is that what the whole have there been
like Real Collectibles that I literally
have not seen any of because I am really
stupid
ah I needed a refreshing drink thank you
oh here we go again
all right I'm assuming that I didn't
miss these and these are only here
and uh that I'm gonna have a use for
them soon
okay
yay
yippee I'm definitely getting all these
for a reason
my name is Cassie foreign
wait I don't have any more tokens
where's the tokens
anybody see any tokens around here
I don't have a flashlight so
you're gonna have to point the tokens
out to me unless I miss the tokens from
before and this is another annoying
thing that I was not getting at the
right time anyway I'll finish this story
and then the boy decided to go into the
basement to see if this monster was
really scary
turns out the monster had big big teeth
and bit the boy in Twain Twain ah
more tokens
Twain means in half then the boy was
crying for his mother but the mother
couldn't hear because she took extra
melatonin that night and was in a deep
Slumber moral of the story is the boy is
dead anyway
that's all the time I got for hunting
coins I think
I best get on with the rest of the story
so that I can hear the horrible ending
of it
I can't I found exactly one more
where am I supposed to get these tokens
and also that's a much better version of
the story than I
I did
I don't know you don't think it was like
available before do you well I don't
know about you I couldn't find any more
tokens so unless there were tokens that
were available like
or before and I missed it I don't know
maybe there's some ahead
hello
tokens
well now I really want the tokens
I want to hear the rest of the story
unless that was a rest of the story but
I doubt it oh
I I did terribly why are there burners
everywhere
it's like the inside of an oven that is
weird
I will admit that is
that is weird
I didn't really question that before but
now I'm starting to
you know
feel like
just saying that that I really tried
and the amount of ass that I'm going to
kick is directly proportional the amount
of things that I missed that were right
in front of my face
trust me the ass kicking is going
to get it's right there
you're telling me that I have been
wasting my time looking in the alternate
reality for these things when there were
in fact secrets in the real world all
along yeah I find that to be obtuse
all right fine whatever I don't find
anything to be obtuse
I swear I swear I swear
I swear I will have my revenge
I will always come back to finish this
do you know how persistent I was in
security breach to get the secret super
secret endings I had to get Pixel
Perfect moves to be able to do it but I
did it and then I did it all without
saving I did it before they patched that
because I'm the best hello
Gregory
that's Gregory's backpack
I wonder if he's around here
Gregory
not right quickly what are you use
machine or what about this thing
what about this silly thing what does it
do
I feel like one of these is going to
lead to an un like an Unstoppable mxes
well I see a weird machine I might use
it
security protocol is the activator are
you sure you wish to proceed
I don't know
oh
hello hi
Gregory
are you in there the stupid door won't
open well
it looks like someone poured concrete
over the door
how am I supposed to get rid of concrete
I know how to get rid of concrete I know
how so what did this do
what's with the rabbit what's with any
of this how have I inadvertently caused
my own demise because I know I have
oh I know I have I know absolutely I
have don't worry I always come back and
I will have my revenge and when I have
my revenge oh you you can believe that
it's gonna be tasty
take that
you okay
uh oh Greg oh crap oh no Greg Greg
also what's with the backpack is that
something what is it with the weird
things oh those are the security nodes
that I exploded the all the security
that they probably put up to contain
this thing whatever this is that I'm
about to go into and definitely is
Gregory
thank you
you're not Gregory
what are you
Gregory
get out of here run oh
[Music]
Cassie can you hear me Gregory is that
really you
I mean really you I'm trying to reach
you all night I'm not at the pizza place
you're a bit late this thing in the
basement sounds just like you
how do I know this is you for real is
there another option you need to get out
of here now how my friend has exit to
the building fast just follow
instructions
your friend help me oh hi oh what am I
looking at what what am I looking at
what am I
am I I'm enraptured
I couldn't possibly what
what is that what is that
what is that
what is that oh yeah run run this okay
I'm running now
Sage old conundrum of where it's really
cool what oh am I listening
I'm supposed to go certain directions
I am aware of that yes thank you
I will I think
I'm going right
man I can't see I well man I really
would love to
cool I
like what wait wait what you really
really really
not in that real oh
hey wait a minute
wait where am wait this is familiar wait
oh are you giving me time to do this oh
God you are aren't you
thank you
well hope I make it
I hope I wasn't I didn't think I would
have time
I really didn't think I would have time
was that where I did I miss something
down there
that was the thing wasn't it that was
the thing
[Music]
I think I need to explain a few things
you were never supposed to go to the
pizza place
tricked you
I really don't know what it is but it's
been trapped down here a really long
time
the Nexus security program was designed
to keep it hidden but you shut down the
security
and now it's free
it's not your fault
I know you did it for me
to save me
but we can't risk being followed
I'm sorry
gregory no
damn Gregory is cold-blooded
damn
I don't accept that I don't accept it
not at all I don't accept a single thing
about this I don't accept anything about
what was going on
wasn't I supposed to watch to the end ah
the one time that I don't were you
actually gonna do I don't accept a
single thing about this oh I don't
accept anything I accept nothing and I
will never accept anything I won't
accept anything because I can't accept
anything what all collectibles found
[Music]
I don't accept any of this I would never
accept anything from anyone ever I know
for a fact that I've missed things and I
will not be responsible for missing
anything not when it comes to Five
Nights at Freddy's security Bridge
going back no progress and collectibles
will be lost
I know
maybe I know
that there has to be something there
that I missed I knew there was something
with those security cameras and then I
found something but what I noticed is
when I opened the first door there was
another door behind it and I think
that's where I was I think that's where
I was
and because that was there and I was
something behind it then there must be
something there for me to get sorry
I don't even care if I have to play
through the whole damn game again
nothing's gonna stop me from being the
amazing Five Nights at Freddy's player
that I am they don't call me the king
for nothing and here's what I want I've
got a lot to do and I've got a lot to
get to but what I don't want is people
trying to tell me I need to do this or I
need to do that I have a good sense of
direction and I figured
a lot of things out in the last game and
I'm gonna figure them out here because I
want to and I must
and I will so what I don't get over here
yeah I know I know I know
I know I um hang on hold on I think I
think here's what I think chapter two is
probably where the AR Adventure Starts
and that's where I need to start from to
be able to get it and if it remembers my
collectibles then I'm probably going to
be able to just go right back to the
front of it if I can get this one thing
but then again there's these weird comic
pages and I don't understand where they
came from because I haven't seen a
single gift box
anywhere in this you
you
was that the last one
well ah
that is illusionary
wait but if I can't put on the mask in
this area how are you illusionary
oh because it'll let me run I get rid of
myself that's how okay got it ah
so then I definitely didn't get all the
Collectibles it said that I got all the
Collectibles but that was just a lie
none of this makes
sense that wasn't the one that wasn't
the one I was thinking that wasn't the
one and what I did okay this was okay
I'm all right I actually was okay hold
on hush I was going for it that wasn't
the one and now I'm going to it so I
hope I didn't just narrate something
saying how dumb I was because I said not
the case
I'll be back
oh I can look up I didn't know I could
look up
I could look up this whole time
what
I thought I was just doomed to look
forward see what I also don't understand
and I'm just gonna say this is what is
the time Jump because obviously it seems
like Cassie and Gregory are still
friends right therefore they're still
kids they're for
isn't this not that far into the future
especially if like
foxy is still or Roxy is still what's
this thing oh right I think it's
supposed to power the door uh how then a
fast wrench how has everything gone to
craft so quickly
that's the deepest piece of lore that I
don't think fits in any of these
theories
okay oh I get to look at the thing that
I missed
do it
what was it nothing happened wait
wait did I miss it
wait what do you mean
oh it was there
wait but I was walking there
but I was literally looking there before
how did I miss it the first
ah
I gotta make it none of this makes any
sense this
don't make sense oh but I don't wanna
you you
thought
you thought you could get away
no
not
at all was that the last one
does it count if I didn't get it all in
one go does it count or do I have to go
oh hi
all collections collected they are
Bonnie pinata
filled with carrot drop candy
that's nice what's that supposed to be
well hi Monty wow pretty quick oh there
there what is that
that was the first one the for what so
that was there did I know about that did
I look at that did I forget that I
looked at that how could I for if I saw
this before which I don't know what I
did but I do know that I zoomed out
I don't know if I clicked on it that's
the thing I might have seen it but not
done anything about it and that would
mean like I don't know if that's the
case but I don't remember I don't
remember doing that I feel like I would
remember doing that I'm smart enough to
know that I would have done that
what
[Music]
don't give me five
five Gregory was always so creative he
sure was you mean to tell me that
sometimes when there were these digital
things there were also physical things
right on top of it because that's where
a digital thing was no I saw what I'm
here for so all right if that is the one
that I missed then there's Apparently
one new one that opens up and so if
you'll know if you got all of them
because this one will be there and if
the if that is the one that I missed
then I have every right to be
unbelievabist the other thing that is
convenient in this level is I can check
the door because if I go to this other
camera here and that previous door is
open that that means I did not get it
when I first played and then it will be
here or whatever it is open and I think
what that is is in that last Chase
sequence there was that door on the left
and one of them was open but the one
behind it was not now there might be
more maybe it's like one in each chapter
you need to open every single door in
there if I C right here what are those
things
they look like the DJ
wait but it's not like it's it's not
doing anything
well then what is that okay then I don't
know what that is
and I don't know what that's for
oh there's a treasure over there
well that's nice I don't even know where
that is
huh
oh
are you the one
good God don't do that hey our golden
Bonnie
a prototype this one looks different
this looks very different so I missed
this one I did miss one in here so it's
supposed to be here
but it doesn't seem to be here so there
must be another that I missed so I just
need to look at a list of like all the
locations and then cross reference what
I may have missed I guess oh oh there's
a couple hidden ones so I don't need to
be enraged because I didn't just miss
that one I missed multiple which is
surprising will you wait where am I okay
you're deactivated so I missed you
before so they that's so that's so weird
how would I
oh I would have sworn that I would have
deactivated that one I bet the doors are
open now I bet they are too shut up so I
can go to the hall over here I remember
looking at this and I I don't think I
went anywhere
weirdly enough
why didn't I go down here
man I'm I'm dumb
oh I'm
I'm dumb
ah
oh
I remember this from the main game or
there was some kind of up here and I
even think that it was a poster this
poster I think you could go through
weirdly enough yeah oh yeah
oh yeah I remember
oh yeah
oh that's different why is that
different that's weird what
that's weird
weird
Golden Moon
looks just like the other one wait
okay I get it
through here
what
it
I didn't deactivate you
now I'm just really confused I did not
deactivate you I I swear I didn't and
the thing about this is I would know if
I came back here because I didn't get
that collectible I don't know if I've
gotten the other ones but I think what
that means is that I'm they must all be
done right that's what that has to mean
because I didn't get that one therefore
maybe it's got like a forgiveness
program where it'll give you one for
free I don't know maybe there's actually
like a bunch and I got just enough to be
able to get there but I think I would
have remembered getting that one
right
okay but this one is not there so I must
have missed one no I think I think I've
definitely seen one here that I didn't
get maybe I did get that one maybe I did
go up in there again did I
oh oh oh
oh
I'm on the stage ah this is where I was
trying to go before hi Monty
backstage oh backstage
oh
what the what the hell am I looking at
you
I've been looking for you
I'm done so is that all of them
are we done I'm just gonna preemptively
check to see if this one because there's
a warning here on one of these that says
it's bugged because Roxy gets bugged and
therefore it gets you and I remember
that happening and apparently it resets
the progress of getting one of those no
but I I swear I got that again
she does get bugged
ah
and yet you're
there
good thing I'd check this one
so do I still have to get jump scared
it's a still thing I have to do probably
[Music]
with that I probably have to still go
back because what happened is I also
died to the race car immediately
afterwards and therefore I didn't see
that or maybe even the race car caused
that one to reset and therefore I would
need to do it again anyway
probably
where am I
you are alive
and with that you might actually be
the last one
unless there was another one in the past
like run where this this has occurred
where I've died
and not realized that I died you know
what I mean
that could have happened let me just
progress a little more so it actually
saves because I think that's what it
needs to do it needs to save before it
can actually do anything and I don't
know for sure if it did
damn it well maybe okay if this is a
case of things not saving maybe it
didn't save the one that I missed in
here because I wouldn't have done
anything significant
afterwards
like maybe it's actually still online
over here
it is because I didn't save does that
mean there's a chance that the ones that
I got before
does that mean that there's a chance
that the ones that I have obtained since
I started this adventure are actually
not obtained because I didn't do
anything to save in the interim oh my
God
it didn't because look I don't have the
other collectible Frick so that means
the one in Monte golf I definitely it
definitely did not save because I didn't
I got that and then immediately left
oh
so when I went up into the poster that
one was already deactivated I don't
remember doing that but it was I'm gonna
just rely on that because it was so what
I'm going to do is I have to go back and
I have to do this one again because well
friction that's just the way it'd be
if you did not say damn it
there there's another one
ah what is that so there's that just the
other door
okay that should have saved I know
there's one that's definitely been done
over here
you you're definitely done okay
hopefully this is the last time I need
to go up to the bowling alley oh would
you look at that
not there
oh no wait
oh no wait oh
it was all in the same chapter
always keep going oh it was I was
actually almost there oh I just
remembered what I missed I just
remembered the one thing that I missed
and it's it's it was all in this one
oh man I would have been faster if I
just played through the whole game again
at this point I could have done a speed
run and got into all of them oh I've
done this one so many times
frick
okay now you guys are gonna see the one
that I missed and I need to make
absolutely sure I save after this one
because I think this is the one that
I've been missing all along because if
you remember I ran into this situation
and I've been doing this so long I feel
nauseous at this point but I'm not going
to let that stop me either because if
you remember came here
and I was so
I was so very much just like oh man
that thing is here again I gotta hide
save me Cassie please save me Cassie
well I wanted to come down here and I
didn't because I didn't know which way
was for it and what do you know
Hi how are you
good to see you
really good to see you
can't believe I missed you before that
might be the last one I don't really
know
how can I know when I didn't even know
that I needed to save after these until
that one I think I got it that might
have been the last one I may just I'm
gonna do this again where I go into the
bowling alley
but if it's not there
I don't think I can keep going oh please
please I'm just oh man
yeah man I really do think it's that one
in the daycare I think it's that one up
there because I do not remember
deactivating that one I don't remember
going up in that area because I
distinctly remember looking down that
hallway and not going down it but it's
like you know I've just been doing this
for so long for for two hours I've been
going back and forth on all these spots
finding things that I haven't found
before and then being like aha this one
and then even going back and being like
ah this one didn't save I better do that
and I know that I got the I know that
the the one at the very beginning like
the the first one of these attendants
that you could possibly get I know it
saved that one because I literally went
forward
when I was when I did that one because I
was like oh maybe I need to get the
second one and then I went forward and I
know that I went forward enough for it
to hit an auto save
I can't
I just can't I don't know why I haven't
gotten a new one I found other Easter
eggs but I have not found that this has
gone on too long and I have to call it
quits here because there's something
going on I don't know what I could have
played through the whole game again I
could have I literally could have gone
through the whole thing again speedrun
and I would be back to where I was but
apparently not and that might be what I
do that might be what I do I might just
play through the whole freaking game
again from start to finish just to be
sure because I can't do this back and
forthy stuff so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought out in the
comments below I've wasted a lot of time
but I will not waste another second
because that's not what I do I'm
efficient and I'm a killer and I'm
every animatronic and I'm gonna
deactivate every floor mopping child
there is
thank you and as always
I will see you
bye-bye
[Music]